[Applause]
all right
let's talk about some real [ __ ] space
jam 2 trailer do we care to watch it
we're adults
[Laughter]
do we care to watch it yeah we're
already you mature already
was it good no it's a little weird was
it weird how long it take you nut
ow ow it's a kids movie yeah
it's a kids movie and he's not saying
pee wee hermes i stay at home
yeah he's at home bruh with his dog
right next to him like a fleshlight
happy happy happy happy
oh my god no but for real
it took not as long as it did in the
first movie tell you that
okay was it was it worth watching what's
the premise like
it's weird it's like kind of dramatic a
little bit
at the beginning like his son is like
you want me to be a basketball player
like you
and then he like runs off and then gets
captured and then lebron has to go save
him
and don cheadle is the bad guy but it's
not a cartoon it's like real don cheadle
with computer animation it's like an odd
thing
and then lebron is animated for a little
bit yeah i don't like i didn't like that
yeah and then the monsters are like
computers and they're not it's not like
cartoon monsters
it's like robot they get 2d 3d and then
like in the real world i just don't like
why not
cast lebron's actual son to play also
weird because the guy kind of looked
like lebron's youngest son he looked
like bryce a little bit
yeah but he calls him dumb which is also
weird will smith played with with
uh jaden like yeah yeah but that may be
funny those movies are trash
because not pursuit of happiness that's
what happened
to happiness no karate kid karate kid
no pursuit of happiness crush though
pursuit of happiness crush
yeah he was like a baby ain't playing
over she didn't say nothing but how old
is bryce
bryce ain't no grown ass kid team isn't
he i don't know we all guessed it
i'm thinking about brawny i'm thinking
about bergolin
hey only fans doc i'm a fan
i'm a fan bro are y'all fans
no you're not uh sure i'm a fan
what kind of clothes would i be if i
left them alone on this island thank you
dude okay
uh okay so so the plot is kind of stupid
it's weird that he has someone looks
like his son but it's not his son
i love space jam maybe it's just because
i was a big bugs bunny fan as a kid
identified with the big teeth and the
smart ass
attitude but this one was just weird to
me it's like
now you're doing too much coogler is
involved ryan quinn oh yeah
he's a beast but i don't know if he's
good for a kid's movie he's great for
like
growing up [ __ ] and like rebooting
rebooting creed and making it dramatic
this was like
it's a kid's movie man yes yes yes is it
one of those kids movies that sometimes
has like heart and like as an adult you
get something else out of it like
remember when you cried onward i did cry
it onward yeah use that [ __ ] right here
and then started whacking right
afterwards
tear jerker tear jerk go right to the
tear jerk
right to the tear jerk right like that
bow bow
power wheels bro i'm not playing games
out here
so i don't think it's going to be that
i certainly didn't jerk off to the
trailer so i don't know or cry i'm not
seeing this stupid movie right
are y'all seeing this movie i don't
think so you're gonna go see it yeah
was the music does the music look like
it's gonna be good because
the song was not great
what what in the original and the new
one oh you're talking about the og
yeah yeah yeah i believe i could fly
yeah
think about it every night and day
i can fly
is jordan nah i gotta keep the same
energy though why because i don't [ __ ]
with delete i can't [ __ ] with her kelly
oh [ __ ] al's really been on this dalia
is our is the white r kelly [ __ ] he is
even going hard he must not listen to
the first 30 minutes
all right so
we're saying that it's not going to be
that good we probably won't support it
but
it's nice to see something kind of pop
back up so there's some nostalgia to it
i guess so i mean we'll see how it i'm
not writing it off as bad for sure
but it just looks weird we're gonna see
how much pull lebron has with the youth
that's yeah i'm curious to see how much
paul lebron has with the youth
my understanding was that steph kind of
yanked some of that uh influence oh i
have a sports opinion off of that
actually
so it's like i think when lebron i think
maybe
before this steph really came out to
start just destroying [ __ ] lebron was
the guy
he was the most influential person in
the league without a doubt like
even kobe i don't think had the youth
towards the end of his career lebron
kind of encapsulated that youth
mentality about what basketball was and
what they want to be
and then as steph came along his game
was so much more transferable to a young
kid
yeah i can't dunk i can't power to the
rim i can't play like this
i can beat the small guy
and shoot threes yeah and shoot over
guys that are way bigger than me
yeah because that's how i feel when i'm
out there i bet you
now i don't know if steph curry is as
like big a figure like
like jordan was still this big figure
right yeah
i don't think steph has that steph is
almost like too
tiny and relatable but his game i think
captured the attention of the youth so
i'm curious to see how many kids will go
see this movie because they love lebron
i will give some push what i'm saying
yes but also here's
what might if it doesn't sell well it
might also be because bugs doesn't have
the same pull with the
great point that's a good point when
space space jam came out there was no
spongebob there was no other [ __ ] it was
bugs bunny and the ninja turtles and
that's about it they did an adam sandler
movie i forget the name of it where they
did
they used all these um old video game
character oh yeah yeah do you remember
yeah i forget what it was called but it
was some netflix movie i think
was it soul or pixel or something like
that pixel something like that right and
uh thanks mark
and uh
so uh so pixel um and the big knock on
that was
that like if you make a movie for kids
you have to use the video games that the
kids relate to
yeah give them minecraft characters
minecraft fortnite
these types of games they don't give a
[ __ ] about miss pac-man right that's our
generation that's our degeneration
before us
right so i wonder if a similar thing
will happen like you say with bugs money
right but also
with lebron yeah does he not have the
influence to the kids bugs bunny
definitely doesn't have the influence on
the kids
wow this might be a flippity flop lebron
like divisive
like i don't know if jordan was as
divisive as lebron would no ubiquitous
rightly or wrongly so like there is a
certain section of the population
whose parents hate lebron james and they
tell their kids yeah
lebron had some innocuous tweet about
going well i was just to that point
like there's a section of the country
that does not like lebron james because
he's choosing to stand for a specific
thing that maybe
a large fraction of the country does not
believe in right
yes but i don't know if he's beloved
like
i it is it's hard i don't know how they
like phrases accurately but like
lebron is respected though
he's probably the most checked goat yeah
of his generation like
people love to bring ah yeah you didn't
have it here like nobody was coming at
jordan like that
yeah right like people love to kind of
take away his greatness
they don't say you had 63 in a playoff
game and lost
you lost nobody says that 63 in a
playoff game in a sentence that's right
not you didn't win
yeah you're talking about jordan jordan
yeah exactly yeah they just bring up
like the accolades they just bring up
the great things
so he's checked often in his greatness
right
but i wonder if
he's as uh beloved
by the people that agree with him like
oh okay do you know what i'm saying like
usually when you're you're an activist
the people that agree with you
they exalt you yeah i don't see lebron
as people i don't see people going to
lebron
thank you so much for speaking out
you're so brave just like there are
other activists that people go to
you know what i'm saying ali ali
was exalted yeah by the people that
agree with him he was bigger than sports
right lebron still exists as this person
in sports
who talks about civil rights yeah i
think
at least it appears to me maybe because
now that we have so many different
outlets of opinions and so many
different like ways of accessing the
celebrities
you can hate or like them for other
reasons beyond activism
ali great boxer activist that's pretty
much all you knew
at the time michael jordan great
basketball player that's pretty much all
you know
at the time lebron you can love him for
an activist love him for a basketball
player but then he's also on social
media all the time
he's on twitter he's got this brand he's
openly trying to be a billionaire he's
got the shop
he makes himself incredibly accessible
which helps in a lot of ways
but there's a lot of other reasons i
could dislike him or not love him as
much
beyond basketball player and activists
because of except the accessibility
that the internet provides there are
many
uh more ways to access his opinions
on the world yeah